who's your lookalike Zoe Saldana and In
fairness it is a picture I mean quite it
is you know it's yeah
even you can see it I know well it
happens when people to my face come and
talk to me people who I've known like
for example bless her heart Victoria
Beckham who I've met a few times okay
and we're in Soul cycle in LA and we're
talking away and this close Jeff okay
and and she's you know she made a
comment about oh it's so great that
you're coming uh to Soul cycle even
though you're you know pregnant I said
oh no I had the baby actually just a few
months ago thinking oh God I obviously
look rubbish
um
and and then after a few more minutes of
chatting I realized that she thought I
was somebody else and I said
um Vic do you think do you think that
I'm Zoe Saldana and she was absolutely
mortified
mortified and you know it's all right
because obviously Zoe Saldana is an
absolute rare Beauty yeah
um and you know it it but it up close
come on come on and I'm English
you need to settle a little controversy
little controversy there was a picture
you've probably seen this it was on the
internet and in in papers and things and
it's this picture here
now oh yeah
people people who are trying to set
aside if that was
Bill Murray or Tom Hanks right right
well I've been doing a pale imitation of
Bill Murray for most of my career
actually works out I know that it's not
me because I did not take that picture
unless I've had a cranial plate shift
that you know is medicinal I that's not
me even even looking at you not you do
yeah no yeah it does yeah I could make
that face yeah we just thought while
you're here to uh to settle things to
avoid confusion in the future we might
re-enact that oh you have an orange
jumper I do I do have some I I I'm fully
costumed oh great I've got some orange
things there okay now Gemma would you
mind being at the I think she's the
mother of the baby so there's some
sunglasses there and now would you mind
being the baby
oh you can do that oh you actually
that's better that's better that's why I
didn't think of that all right okay so
I'm like here
you go there you go you squeeze in
squeeze in like that like they're
smiling okay
there you go that is really good
and I'm so sorry I never thought we'd be
doing this again but viewers won't let
it go the Daniel Radcliffe uh time
traveler you think
it is it is bizarre so now so there's
all the old ones we used to have no that
was the first one we ever showed there's
a thing that happens when we come with
this show where that people sort of uh
dredge the internet and have found
photographs of of people that look like
me throughout time and it turns out
there's a lot of them that's quite a
good one yes
[Applause]
that's that's quite
that's quite that actually that is quite
good I suppose yes that's good that's
very good that's ridiculous oh look
there you are as a nun
oh yeah I feel like getting less like me
this is still one of my favorites
because you look so happy in this one I
think this was this was when you were
time traveling yeah you had a really
good bit of your life here there you go
[Applause]
we bought some new ones the members of
my family now weirdly we found one of
you I think you're married to Robson
Jerome
um
that's a bad part of your life that's a
what month
yeah
this one is good this is again another
very very jolly bit of his life that is
really loving life here hello
Benedict Cumberbatch is also a time
traveler here he is in the 1920s
yeah it's crazy
you made someone very happy in the 1920s
looking in a merry Graham
where did I get those bangs from look at
that I know we got if you want we can
recreate the look if you want to
say I'm glad you said yes because
someone went to a lot of trouble to make
this yeah okay okay well to honor that I
must wear it okay here we come okay yeah
there we go you do that beat yourself to
hurt you
yeah okay yeah that's not bad
[Applause]
a lot of people come up to me and in
fact and say oh my whole life I've been
told I look exactly like you it's so
weird isn't it it's a little bit but
it's a wide range
but I try to be diplomatic I always say
the same thing well that's flattering to
me says I nice I wish I looked like you
no and he's not making up
[Applause]
that's you
he does look a little like you
flattering to me flattering to me
this guy he posted this one there he
goes wait a minute no no I really could
that guy looks like some kind of like
the 50s heartthrob hey he looks
fantastic
check that out yeah and uh oh see this
one he's a bit like a man in glasses
wait a minute hey are you sent out a
young picture of Alan Ginsberg is it I
think that's a young picture of Allen
he's been upset about you for years
he wrote a famous poem called howl I'll
bet you two could recite it and go no
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
a lady emailed us and said oh we're
coming to the show and my husband is
told all the time that he looks like you
so let's have a look at him uh where is
Andy where is Andy now
there's Andy oh no oh actually that
isn't bad
should I go over and uh you know side by
side oh do a side by side yeah let's go
[Applause]
look towards me there's a camera behind
me and it will take a picture of you
okay
thank you yeah thank you
thank you guys thank you so much oh I'm
coming back
wow Andy's wife is kind of looking at
you look oh look an upgrade
no he's very he looked very Suave
now talking of look says that one uh
Bryce one of our good friends on the
show Jessica Chastain yes she's talked
about people thinking
she's you and it's happened and you very
much you do look quite alike here is
Jessica there's there's you that's it
like it is what Jeff said but it's like
really really really true like it's very
flattering to me like she's she's
unbelievable but what I didn't
understand was that it was happening
before either of you were famous yes so
I went to school in New York I went to
NYU and Jess went to school in New York
as well she went to Juilliard and there
were many times I remember this
distinctly either many times first time
it happened I went into a Starbucks and
where people would mistake me for
someone named Jess and so I went into a
Starbucks and I went up to the cashier
and I went to order something he was
like no Jess your your drinks over there
and I was like oh no I I haven't ordered
yet and he was like
and
[Laughter]
um and I just remember being kind of
like it was like a little unnerving
because he was so certain that we were
the same person and then a lot of
friends and it like later in in years to
come would say oh my gosh there's this
there's this woman named Jessica
Chastain and you guys are you know you
could totally be sisters um people often
think that I'm you
laughs
your hair is kind of receding a bit so I
I don't see it yeah why would they think
I get it a lot let's put this together
I'm trying to look as much like you as I
can
[Applause]
yeah I had two women approached me at
this gig and one of them said you're
Graham Norton on you and I said no I'm
I'm not and she said Carl you are you're
the one saying yes just come on you are
in a very forceful way and I thought
I'm not am I I
couldn't be him and I've had a breakdown
just wandering around thinking yeah but
must have happened to me six or seven
times really and when my baby was born
my mother-in-law said oh you know you
know who he looks like Graham Norton
and I thought that that couldn't happen
could it that's very unlike now I'm
consider yet you're one foreign
[Applause]
goal I don't know what you're saying now
whenever about us being from people so
Josh Groban famous all over the world
but it happens to you you get mistaken
for someone I do well it honestly like
depending on my angle I can look like
someone famous or I can look like a
hobbit depending on like how they how
they like me
um they don't exist so they wouldn't
recognize that I was at a concert once
in uh this we had this kind of music
festival called Coachella and I was
backstage and these two big kind of
Rastafarian Jamaican dudes kind of came
up to me and they're like
can we get the picture with your man I'm
like yeah cool I was thinking I expect
expanding my audience this is fantastic
yeah so I took the picture and I'm like
you know do we get it okay is that okay
did we blink I was really excited about
this Photograph and uh and they walk
away and they're like oh man yeah James
bluntman it's James Blunt
[Music]
do you recognize this [__] her face
should come up on the screen do you
recognize that lady I recognize her as a
human on the screen yes
that girl is called Tara is that right
your Tara yes hello Tara I got wave
and and uh anyway she heard you're on
the show and wrote in so apparently you
were friends joint birthday in London
yeah and here Colin they all got very
drunk right okay there's more to the
story than this all right you slept
together
[Applause]
I'm a third child
[Music]
good luck in your movie thank you so
much
yeah could you get my lawyer
no she didn't ask so anyway somebody
came up and said Colin Farrell it was in
the Club Tara writes
I love Colin Farrell
he was actually standing right behind me
blah blah so she goes over to talk to
him and uh anyway you were for an
investment company yeah that had
invested in In Bruges it was involved in
the making of him Bruce so you you
chatted about that Abyss well I thought
it was a good you know opening line
and then you talked about uh your mother
is Irish so you talked about that as
well there's a relationship just grows
yeah and then you have you had a picture
taken with Colin but then the next
morning she woke up and she was sober
she had a look at the picture but now is
it true your friends still sweat blind
it was Colin Farrell yeah
my Yeah we actually do get in heated
debates about whether it was the real
Colin Farrell or not it's do you have
the picture with you because hold up the
picture
okay let's close up of that
it's kind of quite good [__] you is it
no it's kind of me but just more of me
the beard the nose the eyebrows are
impressively bigger than mine let's see
it again that was less than 60 years old
it is quite a meaty head isn't it
yeah you don't look like you're drunk
darling you make a nice looking drunk
so what we're saying is you don't have a
picture of yourself
I'd be my honor do you want to have your
picture
[Applause]
come here
you cannot touch him
just don't sit on the couch
just just squat beside him squat beside
him oh you want to stand up okay
[Music]
oh